- Fricken mosquitoes, so itchy.
- I'm on it, okay.
We got, this for the itching,
this for the swelling,
and Xanax just for fun.
(peppy music)
- Well that's the thing, our anniversary
is next week and I still
don't know what to get her.
- I emailed you my Nordstrom's wishlist,
there are five things on there,
but you only need to get me three.
- I'm kind of hungry.
- Oh, I brought some things.
- No way! - Yeah.
Uh, just a little bit,
corn chips, cookies,
a whole rotisserie chicken.
- (droning) Wow.
- What's wrong, is it not good?
- It's not what I ordered, but it's fine.
I got a burger but it's okay.
- Send it back!
- I'm not even that hungry so...
- Are you joking?
- No...
- Excuse me!
- [Waiter] Hi.
- Hi, this is actually
not what he ordered.
- [Waiter] Oh yeah, let
me exchange that for you.
- Thank you so much, and would you mind,
just cause I'm already almost done,
maybe we can take that off the bill
and also maybe get like a beer
on the house or something?
- [Waiter] Yeah, of course. A Stella?
- Yeah, sure.
- [Waiter] Great.
- Thank you.
- How did you do that?
That was incredible.
- You're allowed to send stuff back.
This one is roasted turkey,
but there's another one
so you can decide, this one is
black bean and sweet potato.
Turns out, he's the one
that's allergic to dairy!
(all laughing)
I know, I know, I know!
Kyle, you didn't tell
me your boss was Jewish,
we go to the same synagogue
and his mom's cousin
is my best friend's sister's gynecologist.
- Her cousin Glen did my
nephew's fiance's colonoscopy.
(chuckles)
- [Woman] How crazy!
- That's crazy!
- She's fabulous, you're coming to dinner.
You like cigars?
- Sure.
- So you just joined the company?
- Five years ago.
- Really?
- Mango guacamole, very fancy.
- You like mango.
- Two bananas.
- Perfect.
- Crackers.
- [Waiter] How is everything?
- The pasta's a little cold, actually.
- [Waiter] Ah, let me
heat that up for you.
- Thank you so much. - Thank you.
- What?
- You're so pushy.
- We're paying for a nice meal,
I don't think it should be cold.
It's not too much to ask.
- That's what I'm sayin'.
- I learned from the best.
- I know you did.
Aw.
Sushi, and two cheesecakes.
- Wow, did you bring anything else?
- I should've gotten more, I knew it.
- [Kyle] It was joke.
Babe, this is feeding an army right here.
- [Woman] You're just being nice.
(whooshing and creaking)